factorizar 27 x a la sexta más 125 este
problema está muy interesante sobre todo
porque es muy difícil de atacar a menos
que los reconozca como una forma
especial entonces lo que quiero ver en
este vídeo es cuál es esa forma especial
de la cual estoy hablando y luego quiero
copiar el patrón que encontremos para
aplicarlo en este problema entonces
déjame empezar haciendo esta
multiplicación la de cuadrada menos ave
más be cuadrada con a más b es muy útil
que sepas esto quizás no en tu vida
diaria pero al menos si para cuando
tengas que resolver problemas como este
de aquí va entonces vamos a hacer esta
multiplicación empezamos multiplicando
esta vez con este trinomio entonces b
por b cuadrada es más b cúbica luego ve
por menos sabe es menos ave cuadrada y
ve por a cuadrada es cuadrada me sale
vamos con la que voy a poner en color
naranja
cuadrada es más ave cuadrada luego a por
menos ave es menos a cuadrada ve menos a
cuadrada ve y aporta cuadrada es
adjudicar
vamos a sumar para ver qué nos queda
los términos de la forma cuadrada vez
desaparecen porque aquí tenemos este con
más y este con menos estos también se
cancelan dos ave cuadrada que está menos
ave cuadrada y aquí más ave cuadrada y
entonces lo único que nos queda es este
cubo adjudica más estévez cúbica más b
kubica entonces este producto de kubica
mashreq ubica o bien otra forma de
escribirlo es que si tenemos una suma de
cubos al cubo más b al cubo entonces la
podemos factorizar como la suma de los
números a más ve multiplicada por a
cuadrada menos ave más b cuadrada de
esto es un truco caso verdad entonces
suma de cubos es igual a la suma de los
números multiplicada por otras cosas muy
bien entonces vamos a ver cómo aplica a
este patrón en el problema entonces para
poder aplicarlo tendríamos que ver que
en efecto tenemos una suma de cubos y yo
digo yo digo que si yo digo que estoy
aquí es una suma de cubos porque ve este
27 x a la sexta
27 si es el cubo de 3 verdad entonces
voy a ponerlo así como 3 y x a la sexta
es el cubo de x al cuadrado entonces
este primer término es 3 x al cuadrado
al cubo y qué pasa con el 25 con el 125
pues el 125 es 5 al cubo quizás debería
explicar este paso un poco mejor para
que quede muy claro 3 x al cuadrado al
cubo que sería sería 3 x al cuadrado por
3 x al cuadrado por 3 x al cuadrado pero
esto es lo mismo que 3 x 3 x 3 x x al
cuadrado por x al cuadrado por x al
cuadrado 3 x 3 9 por 3 es 27 27 y aquí
los exponentes se suman dos más dos más
dos es 6 entonces nos queda x a la sexta
o bien otra forma de pensarlo es que 3 x
al cuadrado al cubo es 3 al cubo que es
27 x x al cuadrado al cubo los
exponentes se multiplican y 2 x 3
sí bueno entonces en efecto tenemos que
esto ya que es una suma de cubos y vamos
a aplicar esta regla está tomando que 13
x al cuadrado esta parte de acá es
y este es el 5 nada más el 5 sin el cubo
es b entonces vamos a ver que nos queda
la factorización nos queda igual
y lo voy a poner en color rosa queda
igual
entonces es a b sería 3 x al cuadrado 3
x al cuadrado más 5
+ 5 y eso tenemos que multiplicarlo por
x a cuadrada a cuadrada voy a hacer eso
por separado 3 por x al cuadrado al
cuadrado esto sería 3 al cuadrado es 9 x
al cuadrado al cuadrado es x a la cuarta
entonces aquí sería 9 x a la cuarta
menos a por ve menos 3 x al cuadrado por
b que es 5 b que es 5 más cuadrada más 5
al cuadrado que es 25 25 muy bien ya
nada más déjame simplificar un poquito
estuve aquí es igual y lo voy a dejar
todo en color verde 3 x al cuadrado más
5 x 9 x a la cuarta menos 15 x cuadrada
+ 25 muy bien entonces aquí ya tenemos
nuestra factorización y este segundo
lado ahorita no nos vamos a meter mucho
con eso pero si estamos en los números
reales entonces ya no se puede
factorizar más vale entonces esto ya es
la factorización de la suma de cubos que
queríamos finalmente es un caso muy
especial es algo muy particular pero
básicamente consiste en reconocer que
tenemos una suma de cubos